hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar why to validate
diagnostic tests I am jus T O'Rourke of
lab roots and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider a virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning let's get started you can post
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind do so simply type them in the Q&A
box which will open when you click the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
sharing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker wieslaw from
laga md associate professor at the
University of Texas Health Science
Center at San Antonio doctor for maaga
graduated from the Collegium medicom at
yay golonski University in Poland and
subsequently completed a residency
program in anatomic clinical pathology
and clinical chemistry he has been
practicing pathology in the university
of texas health science center at san
antonio texas as a staff pathologist and
medical director of clinical chemistry
and the molecular laboratory dr.
fermanagh has been serving on the
instrumental resource committee of the
College of American Pathologists cap
since 2008 since 2009 he has served for
the pharmacogenomics Committee
educational subcommittee working on the
pharmacogenomics educational course he
was actively involved in the clsi on a
project titled method validation by
using patients sample the main
scientific interest is in biomarkers for
aggressive prostate cancer as well as
biomarkers for monitoring trauma
patients with hemorrhagic shock doctor
for [ __ ] will now begin his
presentation
good afternoon everybody thank you very
much for giving me this opportunity to
speak about basic question in diagnostic
lab which is why we validate the test so
let's start from the definition of
validation so as a general for FDA
approved test we need to verify the test
but for FDA modify test or laboratory
developed test we need to perform full
validation and there is some difference
between validation and verification
which is defined by the cop and
definition is on the screen and this
definition are described in general
availability checklist so not tubal and
read this definition we can look at the
few elements which are common for
validation and verification process
which will be testing for analytical
accuracy precision analytical
measurement range physiological ranges
interfering substances by Lucian
concentration and carry over those are
the elements which are common for
validation and verification of the
validation process which is composed of
elements of verification it's also
contains a few exclusive elements which
are the clinical correlation or green
color accuracy that must be included in
validation process for the FDA modify
test or lab develop test and those
audiences in sensitivity and specificity
as well as positive and negative
predictive values so what is FDA
modified test or pre-approved test can
be different from different specimens
type so the in this situation that is
use of alternative collection container
that is different than the manufacturer
approved specimen type this might
require also
establish a new test specific for
alternative container especially
validation of appropriate reference
ranges for doing the specimen type
another will be altered to the range of
linearity most commonly this is done by
adjusting or tuning the second analyzer
which produced a similar the test or
similar results so just tuning the
analytical measurement wrench is just to
bring the second instrument into the
same tune the first one even we don't
seem that this huge modification it has
been treated by CMS such as one the
validation such as required sufficient
patients testing 12 the analytical range
of the secondary instrument and both the
linear response and constant association
with primary instrument must be
shouldering the validation process so
the another will be will discuss
in-house developed test this is the
first to the only method which produce
the results and usually this test is
implement into the laboratory and is
based on clinical study which shows that
recent medical utility for the
particular test the method is developed
by the laboratory but the way of
producing results is based on the same
study and this in-house developed the
test utilize the specific method which
must be validated completely the
laboratory mice make sure that the
testing perform on the level can be
readily expect for the method the
laboratory must also make sure that the
analytical performs of this method is
sufficient to provide meaningful
information in additional validation
should ensure that the results can be
interpreted by using information from
the clinical study or car
available other study this laughs is
done by comparing the results with peer
review publications so let's talk about
the specific element which is done and
which is required by validation with
which you will be clinical accuracy this
information is published on sea life I
document GP can a and I put the
reference on the bottom and other
definition the evaluation of clinical
performance of the test can be divided
in two elements the first diagnostic
accuracy or ability of discrimination
the second decision of efficacy of the
test so what the clinical accuracy is
the NL ailment affecting how much single
test can help the clinician of making
the diagnosis is it is done by by
probability of DVDs quality of the data
which is available effectiveness of
various treatment management and
ultimate mateys probability of outcome
and value and cost which is outcome for
the patients in a common situation and
single laboratory test results is not
the sole basis for making decision on
diagnostic or patients in aschburgh and
it's usually supporting by clinical
decision by other tests for the
preparation and to making the decision
clinical decision solely based on one
test is not a great practice and but
each clinical tool whether it's
laboratory test electrocardiogram or
imaging study means to make some
detonated discrimination sure and this
discrimination can be assessed during
the validation and what is important
important is to assess how accurate each
tool in this discrimination is the green
color accuracy is the most fundamental
characteristic of the eMeter and this is
measure of ability to discriminate again
between two states of health and disease
in addition to that the test must be
helpful to distinguish between benign or
malignant between the responding and
resistance to the therapy or between
different other clinical situation and
without this basic ability so the
clinical accuracy which distinguish
between two states of the of the
patient's fatal condition the additional
element is usefulness of efficacy which
refers to the practice value of the
information in managing the patients so
if there is a situation when there is no
meaning standing behind the results of
the test this test is useless for
clinical practice one of the example of
this situation is when there is not
present of decision cut off between
perfect sensitivity and specificity so
as a summary about the clinical accuracy
this is the concept of clinical accuracy
which refers to the quality of the
information provided by the test and it
should be distinguished from the
practical usefulness of this information
and it should be the element that is the
starting element for evaluation of
usefulness and performance of the test
if the test cannot discriminate between
clinically relevant subclasses of the
subject there is a little incentive to
evaluate and bring the test to the lab
let's say go and remind you some basic
about the accuracy and precision the
best
experimenting evaluated accuracy and
precision is detecting one tube with
establish target value we around this
tube several times and we look we
calculate me and we calculate standard
deviation so the accuracy then the
measure of accuracy is the new which is
the average of the average of the old
test running and measure of the sundered
measure of the precision is the standard
deviation this slide showed the
different scenarios of the instrument
performance in terms of accuracy and
precision diverse the first value are
the spread widely and mean is away from
the target value which shows us slow
accuracy and precision the second
example shows that the mean is right on
the target but the single result is
widely spread which shows us the high
accuracy and low precision the third the
mean is away from the target but the
value is close to each other so it's low
accuracy and high precision then finally
the perfect test with high accuracy on
high precision when mean is right on the
target and standard deviation is small
so this spread is small let's talk about
evaluation of clinical performance of
laboratory tests if we take any
diagnostic test there are three
potential models of distribution of
concentration of the analyzing
population with and without particular
disease the first one on the left is the
is the ideal test which perfectly
separates group of the patients with and
without disease they are cut off
concentration tank perfectly separates
healthy and yo people the distribution
can be expressed as the ROC curve that
illustrate the balance between
sensitivity and specificity for
diagnosis of particular disease
sensitivity and specificity is
calculated for multiple point of
concentration and they are graph of the
curve in this first example the healthy
population is represented by a graph on
the lower part of the concentration and
ill patients of the higher part of the
concentration the cause of concentration
separates level of this particular
analyzed with one hundred percent of
sensitivity and the diagnosis particular
disease of this concentration with
hundred percent of specificity this
ideal test is expressed on ROC curve of
a blue line and cut off concentration
process one hundred percent both
sensitivity and specificity is
representing by a left up right upper
corner on the RLC graft they love lost
craft on the Left represent the
situation in which the concentration of
the ill and healthy person completely
overlap for such situation the
sensitivity and specificity for every
concentration is the same what is
illustrated by straight line on ROC
curve the Garter for such tests doesn't
exist and this place is not better than
50 count the middle example represents
the most common situation in in which
the reserve range of concentration that
is her characteristics for only healthy
patience and concentration that are
characteristic for you patient so the
reset cut off which separate the bulk
group of the patient but there is also
overlap between ill enhancing the
preliminary research data doing the
discovery process most most commonly
evaluate whether
the difference between mean or medium in
healthy and ill patients and if this
difference is statistically significant
in addition the most common reported
value illustrate the clinical
performance of the test is concentration
which best balances the DVD and
specificity and also the area under the
curve which is calculated for different
tests and for comparison of performance
of the test in relation to diagnosis of
the particular disease as I will show
later the impressive large area under
the curve in statistical difference
doesn't mean that the test is clinically
useful the reason of these two
parameters is not evaluated during the
validation process the reason is that
not always those elements are
statistically significant I mean
diagnostically significant if we look at
different concentration related to the
healthy status of the patients will find
the different relation between this tool
if we arbitrary or based on clinical
investigation setup cut off
concentrations separating yield from
healthy patients and discard of his mark
in the block on this slide we're
following this default this sick the
change to this situation first it's
healthy with the negative value of the
test are called true negative but very
sure population which is on the bottom
which is which process negative test but
in fact this negative test is related to
patients who are ill healthy with
positive test and the rest will be ill
with positive tests are the false
positives and true positive the
interesting is that we call the abnormal
test as a positive but from the
patient's perspective in fact this is
the negative mass message this is the
known phenomenon it is bad for patients
when pathologists
but this graph has an interesting
feature there is to medically useful
extreme concentration one which is low
with this hundred percent sensitivity
and second above which is hundred
percent specificity for diagnosis of
particular disease and this extremely
high value are clinically useful and
they are described by mnemonic snout
when the best is highly sensitive
negative results rule out the diagnosis
and spin when with the high specificity
positive results effectively rule out
ruling diagnosis this extreme port are
very useful anti use if the test mass
achieved the different goal and this is
the one of example which is given by the
patients coming to emergency the
department with aggressive behavior and
the best is testing for cocaine the low
cut off processing hundred percent of
sensitivity and is used to roll out
cocaine on the board such cut off of a
significant percentage of false positive
but the emergency department physician
obtained octane clear message which
helps her to manage his patients she is
certain that the patient's behavior is
not related to coke I only use if the
test is negative it is unimportant
information in stressful emergency
situation so they cut off which is well
balanced between sensitivity and
specificity it kinda useless in this
situation similar the high cut off with
hundred percent specificity will be used
by employee clinic screening for abusers
before hiring if the test is positive
for cocaine it must be hundreds
second but it's really positive the
clinic that's not won't falsely accused
of drug abuse for the price of large
number or false nuggets negative results
in the price of missing the large maybe
large number of abuser there's best
balance point of concentration by
significant number of false negatives
and false positive it's useless for the
situation so are as we see for the
marker discovered that is a significant
difference how the results are presented
and in fact this presentation is
important and will be more important for
the laboratory developed test when the
part of initial validation is the
clinical correlation and clinical
accuracy of the task without this basic
ability which is the green color
accuracy and without well-defined
efficacy the diagnostic test is useless
and this is exactly what we need to do
entire evaluation for laboratory
developed desk or FDA modify first let's
look at the three example of real test
two of them are statistically
significant and one is not specifically
significant I'm sorry for the error on
the new-look figure should not be
statistically significant all three are
better than sleep the conch and all
three have a point of well-balanced
sensitivity and specificity the
following example is is real from my
work on discovering of prognostic marker
for patients with hemorrhagic shock if
you know the population showing in
emergency room with a mirage achshav a
life treating condition and currently
evaluation is based basically on
physical examination and an accurate
clinical history patients present in
clinical system symptoms of being in
shock
the depth of this condition and decrease
of and degree of peripheral hypotension
and hypoxia is very difficult to assess
so the precise evaluation of these
patients is so important because of
treatment too aggressive and too low or
too conservative treatment is equally
and may be equally damaging to the
damaging to the patient under treatment
is the risk of immediate debt over
treatment leads to significant
complication in the future such as
metabolic disturbances and multi-organ
failure as today there is no good
partner for assessment of this patient
as a result of our study and which is
shown on this slide we found the Adams
13 activity differs in statistically
significant this to group of the
patients who died and Sue survived a
shark but the future el evaluation
showed that there is no cut off an
extreme sensitivity and specificity this
cutoff cannot be established so the well
balanced cut off individual of ranges of
activity process a sensitivity and
specificity in the wrench and around
eighty percent but there is no
clinically useful this test because in
stressful situation brings ambiguity or
additional uncertainty to the diagnosis
for this patient instead of helping the
clinician the completely different
situation was with p-selectin which in
our limited population show no
statistical difference between the
groups who died patients who died and
who survived by investigation of extreme
specificity and sensitivity show that
varies a cut off at the level of 32
which identified the patients who died
with hundred percent of sensitivity in
reality those patients require very
aggressive treatment
icity of this level was not impressive
but because small but under treatment is
more dangerous for this population of
the patients than over treatment so all
patients even falsely identified at high
risk must be treated aggressively on the
other hand the level lower than thirty
to twenty two percent predict survival
with one hundred percent 70 so the
positive predictive value for survival
one hundred percent the concentration
higher than forty one gives hundred
percent of positive predictive value for
the patients to die for base deficit was
another marker we evaluate similar to
p-selectin we found the cut off
concentration with separate extreme
sensitivity from specificity the
difference between the group was
statistically significant which is
important but the only difference
between p-selectin and base deficit is
specificity which was fifty three
percent on the level of one hundred
percent of sensitivity for base deficit
which was extremely low this example
illustrates that the clinical laboratory
called correlation between level and
clinical situation that was described
before us a clinical accuracy so
important the clinical accuracy must be
tested for FDA for not sorry for not FDA
approved test and as a part of
validation and verification for the FDA
approved test let's look how analytical
accuracy and analytical precision
affects the validated test so let's look
at the median of p-selectin and accuracy
of this there if the instrument performs
with hundred percent of accuracy the
separation is show on this slide is the
great one and it's confirm what was
show on the clinical testing or clinical
evaluation but if the platform on which
the test will be performed it's affected
by complexity of the samples and affect
the accuracy and accuracy of the test in
case ninety percent or inaccuracies ten
percent we show that the range of the
concentration which is measure and low
end will be between 29 35 which is the
lower road similar on a high
concentration the range of concentration
will be between 30 37 and 35 it is
illustrated on this graph both groups of
the patients will still be separated on
this platform but the sun percentage of
the patients are low and high end of
concentration will be mislabeled so this
is the another graph or illustration on
the same situation so let's look what
must be done with a cut-off if we do not
want to miss the patients who are the
higher risk to buy with ten percent of
unprofessional we have to move with our
cut off from 32 to 29 to still have
hundred percent of sensitivity to
diagnose all patients and high risk to
die if we decide to treat only patients
who have a hundred percent risk to die
we need to decrease our up and end of
cut off up down to 37 but they cost will
be to treat the time of the patients who
are in fact not in this group
but if the platform in which we will
perform this test is affected by
complexity of the sample in higher
degree and in accuracy will be twenty
percent the platform will wreak the
level which is cut off of 32 on the
range of 23 to 38 and unhide will be 33
to 49 assists show on the lower road so
if you see that is a overlap between
these two cut-offs and this will be a
great risk to not only misdiagnosed but
also mixed with the patients and the
disc this is the different view the same
situation as we look what happened to
our cut off it is obvious that the test
was reported as a useful become so
inaccurate on this platform that is
absolutely useless and they may be even
harmful for the patients this
illustrates why the required accuracy
must be validated we before test is
offered to the patients with FDA
approved test the relation between
expected accuracy and establish cut off
is hopefully evaluate and verified
before approval is giving to the test
with such a test recommend that accuracy
must be conferred with the patient
sample I would like to emphasize that
the patient sample is useful education
because it is possible that the platform
behaves differently for different matrix
more about that later for their
laboratory develop test or FB a modified
test the experiment assuring that the
low accuracy will not affect cut off and
clinical interpretation must be run and
must be well documented the similar
situation is with the precision so let's
use the same example with selecting the
platform on which the test is
performance affected
about the variation of reaction of the
reagents such as enzyme of antibody
which affect the precision let's assume
that our unprecedented testing is ten
percent so again level of spread of our
cut of amplitude is between 29 and 35
and on higher end between 37 and 45 it
is illustrated on this grub this both
groups steal it can be separated but the
small percentage of patients are the low
and high concentration will be missed
categorized at the situation change if
the unprecedent is twenty percent so cut
off of toward each 32 can be read in
range form between 23 and 38 and I'll
hire cut off between 33 and 49 so de
risa overlap and there is a missed
diagnosis of Miss categorization of a
member of the group which may be unhi or
or lower risk to receive the treatment
or to not receive the treatment so
precision or unprecedent X the clinical
investigation in clinical approval of
this test for this use so let's change a
little big ear and collect spoke about
the linearity and let's talk about
another measurement trench so we before
we discuss discuss discussed the
elements of linearity let's refresh our
understanding of our analytical
measurement range and linearity so
analytical measurement range is the
range of concentration that is linear in
which the sample is measures without pre
preparation linearity is the propulsion
relation between the measured
concentration and reading of the
instrument and linearity is described by
the formula in which they which the
present a represents the slope and B
represents the intercept so this is the
let's start from the linearity which is
presented by vendor coming to your lab
and show that linearity is from zero to
hundred this is the theoretical example
there are three elements that are in
question in this presentation first zero
doesn't exist in love diagnostic
laboratory second linearity is set up
based on artificial samples inserted we
may not meet as long linearity and run
precision is not acceptable on the end
of this linear and must be checked so
what we are doing in diagnostic lab the
first we need to think how long
linearity we need and this assessment is
done by checking medically important
point and to mark this point on
linearity if medically important point
our within the linearity we are okay and
we can evaluate this other the next will
be evaluation whether the unprecedented
escrita important point is acceptable
for clinical purposes example will be
potassium which must be measured at this
point with unprecedented than ten
percent but of course for two more
markets on precision might be higher
fifteen to twenty percent in this moment
will draw the best feet we marked it
sorry in this moment we marked down
precision and we draw the best fit line
it's most likely that the best fit will
change the y-intercept and 0 will be not
an option anymore the best get must
might also they change the slope
we can establish our analytical
measurement French how we are testing we
are testing the concentration and low
end of our linearity until we found that
the last concentration so we'll test the
consecutive concentration the last
concentration that our instrument weeds
with acceptable and precision this last
concentration is detected by the system
with acceptable unprofessional and our
lower point of quantitation and we do
the same on the upper end with this high
concentration until high concentration
until the highest concentration show us
with unacceptable and precision this to
concentration will limit our linearity
and will be called another tackle
measurement wrench so the concentration
between this extreme points this is
Donald Kyle measurement range and it's
validated with the patient sample it's
important to test analytical measurement
range again with the patient sample
because it's possible that
unprofessional precision change depends
on the type of the samples and anyway
our goal to validate the instrument in
diagnostic lab is to test the patient
sample not QC sample or not to calibrate
it is common event that analytical
measurement reg does not cover entire
range of concentration that is needed in
clinical practice so to extend the
reported concentration up and down above
and below analytical measurement French
we have to validate our dilution
protocol and concentration protocol and
again both must be tested with the
patient sample and eluant which will be
used in the future the game this testing
is related to the matrix effect dilution
with
unions must not give the same recovery a
solution with normal styling the same is
true with the proportion of the patient
sample and developed so the higher
concentration or Die higher dilution
doesn't mean we'll behave the same as a
lower dilution it is possible that the
recovery will change and become
unacceptable if the sample ratio to die
if the racial to sample and diluent
change or increase right now is the time
to look at the lower point of
quantitation lower point of quantitation
was established before I just want to
remind you is the lower point of
quantitation is the lowest point of our
analytical measurement range which is
which our instruments perform in
acceptable and precision the next step
will be test point zero in proposed
linearity from anyone experience we know
that the running blank we always get
some reading from the instrument if the
test Blanc if we tested 100 times we are
obtaining the range of concentration
that is different from 0 and this mark
on this on this slide of the circle is
around us a zero if we did the precision
that will be testing one sample about
five times of the constitutive
concentration that is lower than lower
point of quantitation on some point the
concentration concentration gives us the
same reading as a blog at this
concentration our instrument is not able
to differentiate blank from the patient
sample so the last concentration which
gives us the consistent instrument
reading
is different than reading from the blog
this is our lower point of detection
these two values lower point of
quantitation and lower point of
detection a very important point in
creating the clinical reports for this
unalike and this is the some example of
our report so if our report so if our
report is purely quantified we should
not report anything below our lower
point of quantitation because the
precision of measurement below this
concentration done by our instrument is
not clinically acceptable so the report
will be less than lower point of
quantitation which is mark on this slide
but maybe the clinical situation that
the clinician you would like to know if
there is any amount of analyte of
interest that will be with for example
viral load if we test for EBV or MC MC v
or will be for PSA for post post respect
to my patients hourly report will
consist or three categories quantitative
number which is above the lower point of
quantitation the report which is
detectable which will be between the
lower point of quantitation and lower
point of detection and not detectable
which will be lower than point of
detection we try not to report 0 because
we in fact we don't know the risk order
is not present inside mattrick's effect
so the matrix effect is the phenomenon
that is not only detected by laboratory
ins but also was detected and
acknowledged by CMS and clear and takes
on the regulation and Patricks effect
was relayed
just to detecting for the proficiency
test and matrix effect is the fact of
analytical effect which is integrated
into the interaction between proficiency
tests Inc material and stress system and
leads to analytical biased so affected
proficiency testing usually agree with
the results obtained from the same
system but do not agree with the results
with other system or in affected sorry I
didn't change this slide so this is the
sum of the elements of Clea regulation
which is related to magic effect so
first it says that the buyers are not
predictable and correctable this is true
so each proficiency testing in each new
matrix should be tested on particular
platform because the effect will be
unpredictable and we cannot refer to
reference method if we evaluate the
concentration which is affected by ma
fix effect because the reference method
that may not react the same so the
evaluation of this concentration must be
based on peer group and sometimes the
matrix effect in obscure Lea real
difference between the different systems
so much it affects can show the
similarity but in fact for the patient
samples will be different so this is the
reason why do you do much expect during
the validation of verification process
we should confirm our analytical
measurement French precision on
medically important points delusion and
concentration protocol by use only the
patient sample
so what happened if there is a situation
when our validation and dilution does
not give us the number we need for
clinical report if report of our
concentration is higher than needs to be
or it's asked for the clinicians so that
is a situation when especially in
analytes which a high concentration one
of an example will be HCG in patients
with choriocarcinoma or moral pregnancy
that clinician ask not ever not about
the higher done but the number because
he needs this number for monitoring the
progress of patients treatment and
progression of the disease in this
situation to prove that the matrix does
not affect our dilution we may do to
dilution and calculate the recovery if
the calculated concentration are within
the acceptable precision we may assume
with high 70 that our dilution or new
deletion a new dilution ratio is not
affected by magics and we can accept the
results at the same time this validation
of the nude illusion might be documented
and might be implemented in future
testing and might be taking us an
extension of our reportable ranch
instrument compatibility so there is a
regulation which tells us that
instrument must be testing for
compatibility and this is done in two
different situation one situation is
during the validation process and second
is required to do this every six months
it which is required not only for clear
also is required by by c.a.p for the
6-month compatibility different type of
samples are acceptable and those are
listed in this slide but for the
validation I strongly recommend from my
experience to use the patient samples to
compare the different instrument for the
concentration we should use to compare
different instrumental and validate
different instrument can be low mid and
high according to clear regulation with
in analytical measurement wrench but
also can be within medically important
points especially during the validation
and if we consider compatibility
compatibility between the instrument as
a test for our reference ranges and
criteria for interpretation of
compatibility of the instrument can be
different going to be based on
unprecedent and standard deviation and
to standard deviation is usually the the
acceptable in precision second can be
within acceptable unprecedent articular
test which is expressed in percentage of
different different or results must be
plus minus greatest imprecision for this
group of the instrument and the results
of the compatibility can be graph of
this show on this flag so why we do
comparability between the instruments
when we do the validation let's say
situation we are bringing the new
instrument to our board which is
technologically much better and more
advanced but we still compared to the
old instrument what is the sense is
because we would like to transfer
reference ranges from the old system to
the new system which saves us a lot of
work because the reference ranges study
requires hundred twenty male and one
hundreds Pony female sample testing
which are free from disease we are
looking for and as illustrations of
compatibility testing i'm using the
comparison between point-of-care testing
and which is illustrated by two upper to
upper graph after evaluation criteria we
look at the how close the red lines are
the cross closer these lines are the
better correlation black line represents
the ideal correlation closer the single
points to the black line is the lower
difference between the instrument this
to upper graphs represent the constant
and proportional bias between the two
instrument usually we are ignore that or
we can live with that with the
proportional cost and bias and the
reference ranges can be adjust to that
but it's the lower end or the lower
graph shows us the compatibility between
point of care and traveler tory
instrument which is the main instrument
as you can see the the distance between
the red lines are huge the point of
single measurements are away from the
black line in the middle so there is a
huge discrepancy in testing on both
laboratory and POC in addition the
difference is unpredictable to the
extent that we may see at least ten
percent or ten percent of outliers and
people have knowledge that and because
of that p point-of-care test or point of
the instrument is not used for diagnosis
is used only for monitoring of the
patients carry over so what carry over
is let's go to definition so from the
bookkeeping carry over is the total on
one page account which is carried
forward to the next page but in
laboratory test is intended
offer of analyte from 12 to the next one
and there is a huge regulation and very
strict regulation from the CMS and also
from JP and there are several regulation
regulate how the carryover should be
detected and must be detected so I give
the one of example from the molecular
lab how carryover can be detected in
fact it's the the setup of the samples
and each round is set up like this sorry
it's set up like this so we put the blog
between high and low sample between high
control and the samples to protect or to
detect Gary carry over from high control
to the samples and try for transfers
also the samples to the low control this
slide show you one of the practical
example how to test for carry over
during the validation process cup
recommends to do the experiment with
only three high samples which are tested
and 33 low test sample which are tested
after that the third high sample is the
true hi the third law sample is too long
the first low samples usually represent
the contaminated example and calculation
and evaluation is against the
unprofessional of the number carry over
is less than done precision which was
established during the validation
process there is no carryover detected
this likely present a little bit extent
or more extent experiment for carry over
and as you see that is the five high
five loss and five high number five high
and then I represent the true high
number five flow represent the true
remember one low represent the
contaminated low concentration and the
difference between low five and slow one
represents the amount of carryover or
different a high six a high six
represent the carryover or contamination
from Dylan which is transferred from the
low concentration into the high
concentration so this experiment aims
for two elements they first identify the
carryover of high concentration into the
low concentration and carryover of
diluent from the low concentration too
high and the formula to calculate this
is show on dislike the evaluation is
against the precision which is
characteristic for this particular
experiment as you know during my
presentation I emphasize the matrix
effect so if we evaluate the carryover
against the unprecedented up during the
validation we may be misleading and we
may be not identified they carry over or
identified falsely but if we have we run
five samples we can easily calculate the
standard deviation and unprecedented
this particular experiment and three
late hour carry over against the
standard deviation and I'll precision
for this test cut off for qualitative
desk is must be validate before test
start and every six months of the docs
and for the confirmation of cut off for
the qualitative molecular tests such as
microsatellite instability the samples
with no concentration of a great copy
should be used in this experiment we use
the samples with one ten fifteen hundred
and thousand copies in addition we use
blog and we use also the normal samples
we are looking for results of the after
running the different number of cycles
and what we see that the looking of the
results with the sample with ten copies
which crossed the threshold line on 32
cycles and this shows that it's nothing
different done from the normal sample it
means that at this level SI cannot
differentiate between normal and
abnormal cells the specific application
begins below 31 cycles but we don't have
concentration of the copies the next
concentration is 50 copies which shows
us the cross line on 28 site cycles so
with this validation data we confirm
that cut off at the level between 50 and
10 copies and is between the 28 and 31
cycles so for the confirmation every six
months this is experiment how the
experiment should looks like the we have
to consider carry over so we put the
blank between high concentration and
sample with ten copies and we put long
between sample of 50 copies and negative
control and if results show like that so
we show that after twenty eight cycles
this of ten copies this negative example
of fifty copies is positive we can set
up cutoff for molecular test on the
level of 20 ASAP cycles and we can
report that cutoff for us is 50
copies or of the nucleic acid the
another example of validation of cut off
is for HCG pregnancy test most of the
pregnancy testing process on precision
about fifteen to twenty percent if cut
off of conception of the positive is on
the level of 20 units per liter win for
validation of cut off we need to find
the sample which is slower but close to
16 on the lower end and this is the
negative sample and higher than 24 for
positive results we try to be as close
as possible to this concentrations not
to exceed some vendor provides the
samples with the concentration of in
thousands or concentration in zero for
negative and thousand for positive it is
not proper how we should validate and
and confirm our cut off and I believe
this is the end of my talk thank you
everybody for attention and please if
you have any question thank you dr.
filmographer your presentation a quick
reminder for the audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box down by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window dr. for manga will
answer as many questions as time permits
and I will give you a moment to submit
your question
keep there and if there are no questions
I would like to once again thank dr. for
manga for his informative presentation
do you have any final comments dr. from
other yes thank you very much everybody
for for listening and my talk was
focused on first to the validation with
the patient sample and second if this is
FDA not approved test or modify test it
requires a lot of work and to look at
this from the perspective of a cut-off
and usefulness in diagnosis thank you
very much everybody thank you again and
I would also like to thank the audience
for joining us today this webcast can be
viewed on demand through May eleventh
2016 lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye